- During that point,
what did I do?
Is I did what I preach to all of
you which is I put in the work.
I gave up all my weekends and
holidays in high school because
I knew I had to pay that price
because I wasn't gonna do the
I'm gonna go to school, meet
some good kids at Stanford and
Brown, Ivy League school.
Make some relationships and
that's gonna be my springboard.
I was gonna start with no
relationships and in the gutter
and I was gonna have to prove it
and I would have to show up and
meet everybody like I did in my
30s but in my teens and 20s,
I was gonna have to work.
And so what I did was to the
extreme of anybody I've met that
had options, some people lose
their father, mother, welfare
but anybody who had some
options, I punted every leisure
activity in my life.
Nothing, no weekends,
no vacations, zero, nothing.
Nothing.
Like we're making jokes about
the seven days, I didn't take a
single, and by the
way, it's my truth.
I didn't take a
single vacation day.
Never and I'm sure you
worked on your side hustle,
I just love you and
I didn't want to razz you.
None.
Zero, zero, zero.
All my high school friends,
gone, because I wasn't around.
All my college friends,
post-college, gone.
I'd see them a little bit.
I love those guys but gone.
Girlfriends, nothing.
All-in.
So what did I do?
I worked.
I worked to such an extreme
level that when I push you on
work, I don't even ask you to
do 50% of what I did and
I guarantee you'll fucking win.